["Money, Love, Speed"]
Guys, welcome to Money, Love, Speed.
And we're gonna talk really quickly.
I'm gonna share what the one-pager is,
why we use it, and then when we should use it.
Okay, I'm gonna go really quick.
We're gonna get this done,
because guys, let's go make some money.
Number one, what it is.
Very, very simple.
Think about a website and think about the home page, okay?
So, we're not gonna build that entire website.
We're not gonna have service pages, location pages,
about us, all that crap.
We're not going to do that.
We are gonna build a one-page landing page
that we're gonna send traffic to,
and that traffic is gonna convert into leads,
and we're gonna do the least amount of work possible,
the minimal viable product.
We're gonna just have enough
where people are gonna hit the website
and they're gonna call the phone, fill out the form,
we're gonna generate leads, okay?
It's very simple, don't overthink it.
Just think about a regular website, a home page, okay?
There are certain things that we do need to include
on this home page, and I'm gonna go over those,
but everything outside of that,
you don't need to worry about that.
I will tell you, it is worth your time
taking your time building your template
for this first go-around.
Then after that, you can literally copy and paste it
and switch out the content, switch out the words,
switch out the, or just the same thing,
switch out the background image,
switch out the phone number,
and it becomes very quick and easy, okay?
So, that's what a one-pager is,
and some of you guys are watching this video
and you are going to go pre-sell a site, okay?
Great, welcome.
Some of you guys went and you sold a site
that you already had,
and now you're getting ready to pre-sell a site, okay?
There's gonna be multiple different reasons why you're here,
but this is what you're going to do, okay?
So, why do we do it?
Well, number one is speed.
We want to do this as quickly as possible.
We wanna do this as quickly as possible,
as cheaply as possible,
because, as I've said many, many, many times,
money loves speed, okay?
So, we wanna do that as quickly as possible,
and that is why we're going to be building the one-pager.
So, speed, speed, speed.
Secondly, we are gonna be building this
on what's called a sub-domain.
So, we're gonna be doing a .wix, a .weebly,
whatever, you could use WordPress.
We're gonna be doing this on a sub-domain,
and what that means is we don't have to pay for the domain.
So, instead of having to go buy the, you know,
cedarcityconcrete.com or minneapolisconcrete.com,
this is gonna be minneapolisconcrete.weebly.com,
and we're not gonna have to pay for it.
So, speed, cost.
The other thing that's really awesome about this
is it allows us to test the market
without having ongoing recurring costs.
So, it has kind of a combination
between the other two things that I said.
We're gonna be able to build this one-pager
for very little time, very little money,
and quickly go and test the market,
and if it doesn't work,
we spend a little bit of money on ads,
and there's no buyers,
or we spend a little bit of money on ads,
and no one calls,
we didn't spend all of our time, effort, and money
building out a full website.
So, those are just a couple of reasons
why this is such a valuable tool.
The thing I love the most, above all, is the speed.
The fact that I could literally look at a project
and say, hey, I need a one-pager in Minneapolis
for concrete, and I could have that one one-hour's time,
and I would have no money spent into it.
That is a amazing thing, okay?
So, that's what it is, why we do it,
and then thirdly is, when should you do the one-pager?
Okay, when should you do,
when should you utilize these one-pagers?
And it's up to you, this is your business.
You're free to go build out full sites, okay?
You're free to do your homework on the niche in the city,
and just go build the full Monty.
That's you, if you hate money, go do that, okay?
However, I'm gonna tell you that the answer to this
is I use the one-pager every single time,
every single time.
Let me give you one example.
So, we have a client right now, he's a masonry guy.
We call him the other day, we're like, hey, are you happy?
Just kinda checking in, he's like, yeah,
everything's going great.
He's like, I actually have a friend, he does excavation,
he wants to use you guys,
he wants to get some leads from you guys.
So, keep the deals done, right?
We're crushing it for this one guy,
he referred us to his buddy, deal's done.
We're like, okay, cool, what should we do?
And in the past, I used to just like,
because I got the deal, I'm like, oh, I'll just go
and build out the website because we're using his money.
The deal's already done, right?
That's not what we do anymore.
Now what we do is, I'm actually going to sign the deal,
I'm gonna get his money,
but before I go build out the full website,
I'm actually, for the first at least three months,
I'm gonna be running ads to a one-pager.
Now, why would I do that if I already got the deal?
Well, I'm not familiar with excavation.
I don't know if that niche is going to really work
in the city we're targeting.
I just don't, part of my gut tells me
that it's too commercial heavy
and that most people are gonna know who to call.
I don't know if it's gonna work.
So instead of building out a full site,
even though it's his money, I'd rather keep the money,
use an MVP, what I mean by MVP is a minimal viable product,
which is like a one-pager, okay?
Use a one-pager that costs me no money, no time.
I run it for three months, and if it's crushing it,
okay, cool, in three months, we take some of the profits,
we build out the full website, and we like,
hey, this niche in this city works really well, okay?
However, if we do this, and a couple months in,
we find out, hey, the calls we're getting,
they're not really the leads this guy's looking for.
They're kind of just random stuff,
people looking for jobs, whatever it is.
Now I can go to him and say, hey, here's the deal.
We have a six-month agreement,
but this isn't really working.
The niche city doesn't, you know, whatever.
I didn't build out a full website.
I don't have this hosting bill and this tracking number
and all this stuff I gotta take care of.
I didn't have to pay for the content.
I didn't have to pay employees to build this out, right?
And I still made a profit.
So I use the one-pager every single deal.
Even if it's a layup, hey, here's a referral,
I use it because I wanna test it
and make sure that I pick the right city.
Maybe I'm looking at the Dallas-Fort Worth area
and I have a guy that covers all the area,
and he's like, hey, I would love to get leads in Arlington.
Okay, cool, so what I'm gonna do
is for the first couple months,
even though I got the deal, it's a referral,
I'm gonna go do a one-pager probably in Arlington,
Plano, whatever cities that he's interested in,
and I'm probably gonna run a test
with these three different landing pages
to see which one's getting me the cheapest, best leads.
Okay, so just a few examples.
One last thing that I really like to use this one-pager for
is if I have a client in a big city, let's say Atlanta,
and we got the deal, I did the one-pager,
we went through the process, I got the deal.
But two months later, something happens
that's not ranking that quick,
and the business owner's like,
Nick, I need more leads, or whatever,
and they're kinda getting frustrated,
I can tell they're getting frustrated.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go and research
some of the suburbs around Atlanta,
so Norcross, Marietta, maybe Flowery Branch,
and I'm gonna do the homework on those.
And then I'm gonna be able to go build one-pagers
in Marietta, in Norcross, maybe in Flowery Branch,
and run ads to those landing pages
and supplement that deal, he doesn't even need to know,
say hey, I'm just gonna keep pushing him leads,
he doesn't know that it's coming
from a separate landing page,
they're all just gonna funnel to him,
and it's a way that you can kind of increase the leads
if things get a bit stagnant,
and it's a beautiful way to use that one-pager.
So there's a ton of application,
there's a ton of use for these one-pagers,
my biggest piece of advice is learn how to do this,
build a kick-ass template, learn how to do it,
master it, and then we can go to the next step,
which is outsource it, but you are going to be using this
on every single deal,
because we are going to use other people's money
to build our empire.
["Same Love, Same Love"]